how many of you have had your doctor ask
you about sex your mental health alcohol
use these questions are almost universal
but how many of you have had your doctor
ask you about money most of us haven't
but that is strange because compared to
most high income countries child poverty
is an epidemic in the United States
it creates conditions that may elevate
stress hormone levels and impair brain
development poor children in the US are
one and a half times more likely to die
and twice as likely to be hospitalized
as their middle-class counterparts so my
colleague dr. Michael hull and I started
asking moms about money we knew we
needed to reimagine what a doctor's
visit looks like to get kids out of
poverty and to give them a fair shot at
a healthy life our questions led to a
surprising solution tax credits it turns
out the Earned Income Tax Credit or EITC
is the best poverty prescription we have
in the US the average mom gets two to
three thousand dollars a year from it
when families get it moms and babies are
healthier fewer depressed moms babies
weighing more at birth but one out of
five families who could get it doesn't
and most who do lose hundreds of dollars
to the for-profit tax preparation
industry one day a mom asked us why we
couldn't do her taxes while she waited
for the doctor we all know that
purgatory why not make good use of that
time so we started street-cred an
organization prescribing tax preparation
and clinics serving kids this is a brand
new approach and one that left some
questioning our sanity after all we're
doctors not accountants but we have
something accountants don't
access to families over 90% of kids in
the u.s. see a doctor at least once a
year
their parents trust us and will do
anything to give them a better life
doctors in every clinic around the
country could be doing this work - it's
simple really the hospital registers as
a tax preparation site and everyone from
medical students to retirees can
volunteer as a tax preparer after
passing an IRS exam it's not as hard as
it sounds I promise I certainly never
thought I would be doing other people's
taxes but here I am we're nearing the
end of our third year in the 1st - we
were turned 1.6 million dollars to 750
families in Boston alone this year this
year we've expanded to nine sites in
four states 63% of our families have
never heard of the EITC how can you
claim something you haven't heard of and
a half have never used free tax
preparation that two to three thousand
dollars a year goes a long way take
hunger an adequately nutritious low-cost
diet for a mom and two young kids cost
four hundred and seventy seven dollars a
month with a ITC money that family can
eat for five to six months or think
about medical care twenty million
children in the u.s. lack access to care
meeting modern pediatric standards and
yet the average cost of that care is
only four hundred dollars per kid per
year a ITC money can help fix this
access problem perhaps most powerfully
of all this money gives moms hope one
mom used her refund for her son to study
abroad in Spain she was struggling to
pay her rent but she saw a ITC money as
his shot at a better future
we have an opportunity as
actors and as citizens to get to the
root of this problem we can reimagine
healthcare is a place addressing the
causes of poor health be it infections
or finances thank you
[Applause]
[Music]